bonjour Claude malurey merci d'être
votre invité ce matin sénateur de
l'Allier président du groupe Les
Indépendants République et territoires
vous êtes membre du bureau politique
d'horizon le parti d'Édouard Philippe et
on va parler de votre rapport puisque
vous avez remis hier votre rapport sur
le fonctionnement et la stratégie
d'influence de Tik Tok Tik Tok c'est ce
réseau social d'origine chinoise c'est
une application une application pardon
qui est utilisée chaque mois par 150
millions d'Américains 150 millions
d'Européens on va en parler avant de
parler de vos recommandations quel est
le problème avec Tik Tok quel dérive
alors il y a plusieurs problèmes d'abord
il y a un problème de toutes les
plateformes on connaît leurs défauts les
fake news les les élections trucs
influencé la haine en ligne le
harcèlement c'était un bref ça c'est
toutes les plateformes TikTok en plus à
deux problèmes particuliers il en a
d'autres mais il a deux particuliers le
premier c'est que vous disiez il est
d'origine chinoise mais il va seulement
d'origine chinoise il est resté lié à la
Chine avec le contrôle évidemment du
Parti communiste chinois avec des
transferts de données massif vers la
Chine ce qui pour le moins évidemment
vous imaginez surtout avec 150 millions
d'utilisateurs aux États-Unis en Europe
ça fait beaucoup de données qui partent
qui partent en Chine donc c'est un
premier problème majeur d'ailleurs Tik
Tok est déjà interdit pour la plupart
des fonctionnaires de tous les pays
européens
et donc c'est bien la preuve qu'on
connaît déjà le problème et puis le
deuxième problème parmi d'autres c'est
un algorithme extrêmement addictif qui
retient les jeunes parce que ce sont des
jeunes non seulement ce sont des
adolescents mais pour beaucoup ce sont
des enfants avec une proportion énorme
d'enfants de moins de 13 ans ceux qui ne
devrait pas exister d'ailleurs Tik Tok
lui-même la société dit nous ne sommes
pas là pour les enfants de moins de 13
ans il n'empêche qu'il n'y a pas de
contrôle d'âge et donc un algorithme
extrêmement actif une moyenne de deux
heures par jour passé sur l'écran quand
je dis par jour c'est parfois par nuit
avec toutes les conséquences scolaires
cognitives etc donc il y a d'autres
problèmes mais ces deux problèmes là
sont sans doute sans doute des problèmes
majeurs et ce qui est à l'origine
évidemment de votre apport dont on va
parler alors vous dites qu'il faut mieux
contrôler
TikTok pourquoi ne pas être allé jusqu'à
demander son interdiction alors nous
avons je
crois qu'il faut essayer d'être
constructif
même si les réseaux sociaux c'est
difficile d'être constructif avec eux
parce qu'il se moque des lois ils sont à
l'internationales dans on a du mal à les
poursuivre quand on en fait une amende
ça représente une goutte d'eau parfois
des amandes énormes mais ça représente
une goutte d'eau par rapport à leur
budget donc c'est compliqué il n'en
reste pas moins qu'il faut être
constructive et puis quand vous avez 150
millions d'utilisateurs vous pouvez pas
dire du jour au lendemain en couple
ruiné il faut quand même expliquer donc
l'idée c'est de dire nous exigeons une
mise en conformité notamment par rapport
aux règles européennes qui ne sont pas
respectées actuellement sur l'Internet
les règles sur la confidentialité sur
cookies etc donc nous exigeons une
conformité et si vous ne réalisez pas
nous proposons de suspendre
l'application non pas de l'interdire ou
de la ou de la fermer définitivement
mais une suspension jusqu'à ce que on se
mette en comprimé on n'est pas là pour
brandir le gourdin mais et on préfère
que la menace suffisent pour se mettre
en conformité et vous laissez au
gouvernement jusqu'au 1er janvier 2024
pour se mettre en conformité si au à Tik
Tok je comprenais janvier 2024 et vous
dites si Tik Tok n'est pas en conformité
au 1er janvier 2024 vous demandez au
gouvernement de suspendre et de demander
à l'Union européenne de suspendre est-ce
que depuis la remise de votre rapport
hier vous avez eu un retour du
gouvernement là
le rapport était remis hier en fin de
matinée évidemment nous avons eu
auparavant des discussions nous avons
reçu en audition Jean-Noël Barrault le
ministre du numérique on a discuté avec
Bercy etc et donc c'est pas une surprise
pour eux ils savent que notre rapport va
être quand même assez
musclé mais ensuite bien entendu nos
recommandations c'est celle du Sénat
nous n'avons pas le pouvoir de décider
tel ou telle chose nous avons le pouvoir
de le suggérer et je pense d'ailleurs
que ça va déclencher des vous savez
qu'en Italie l'Italie a déjà suspendu
Tik Tok à la suite d'un défi
idiot ou une petite fille est morte dans
une sorte de jeu du foulard il y a
d'autres situations comme ça
est-ce que cette demande c'est un moyen
de mettre la pression sur Tik Tok ou
est-ce que vous pensez que le
gouvernement pour aller jusque là où
c'est irréaliste de penser que Tik Tok
sera suspendu
chez les deux c'est d'abord un moyen de
pression moi je préférerais que la
menace suffisent mais je peux vous dire
que si ça n'est pas réalisé si la
rupture des liens avec la Chine qui est
évidente à travers une société
complètement
invérifiable aux îles Caïmans enfin
TikTok se flatte toujours d'être
transparente transparent transparent en
fait c'est une opacité totale et la
première chose qu'on fait lorsqu'on part
de la Chine c'est de faire une société
aux îles Caïmans si vous appelez ça de
c'est le numéro 2 dans les classements
le numéro 2 des paradis fiscaux derrière
les îles vierges pour l'opacité voilà
donc ce genre de choses nous nous
voulons connaître le capital de la
société qui vote dans la société quels
sont les liens avec la Chine il me
paraît assez normal d'ailleurs que un
gouvernement européen que tous les
Européens avant de délivrer des
commissions avant délivrer des
autorisations
on aimerait savoir le capital de votre
maison mère personne ne l'a demandé
c'est quand même un peu étonnant on va
parler dans quelques secondes des liens
avec la Chine et des données
personnelles mais un mot puisque vous le
disiez l'autre problème c'est le
contrôle de l'âge il y a une proposition
de loi qui a été votée par le Parlement
à l'initiative de votre collègue horizon
Laurent marquant instauré une majorité
numérique donc en plus s'inscrire sur un
réseau social si on a moins de 15 ans
est-ce que du coup
sans accord des parents est-ce que là du
coup ça suffit vis-à-vis de Tik Tok ou
est-ce que vous vous en demandez encore
plus
le problème c'est pas qu'on puisse
s'inscrire ou qu'on puisse pas
s'inscrire ça c'est une évidence le
problème c'est qu'on contrôle parce que
si vous dites Richelieu disait votez une
loi et ne pas la faire appliquer c'est
autorisé ce qu'on veut interdire on est
exactement dans ce cadre là cette loi
vient d'être votée c'est une très bonne
chose mais il y a déjà d'ailleurs il y
avait déjà des lois mais à partir du
moment où vous ne le faites pas
aujourd'hui Tik Tok nous dit
l'application est interdite au moins de
13 ans vous vous rendez compte que 45%
des 11-12 ans sont sur TikTok c'est à
dire qu'il y a zéro contrôle d'âge donc
nous ce que nous non et le contrôle là
c'est compliqué on le ça c'est demandé
désormais pour les sites pornographiques
par exemple et pour le moment ils sont
toujours pas exécutés le seul contrôle
DSA le règlement européen va être mis en
place à partir du 27 août donc à partir
de toutes les grandes plateformes sont
obligées de faire un contrôle d'âge et
là je pense qu'il ressembleront pas si
c'est une plateforme ne le ne le réalise
pas je crois vraiment qu'il suspendront
jusqu'à ce qu'ils se mettent en accord
le problème c'est que le contrôle
d'acheter c'est compliqué il faut parce
que ça pose aussi des problèmes de de
droit de droit individuel le contrôle de
l'âge c'est c'est en rapport avec votre
identité et donc il y a des gens qui
veulent bien faire un contrôle d'âge
mais qui veulent rester anonyme sur
Internet ce qui est parfaitement normal
donc il faut un tiers de confiance c'est
un peu compliqué il faut des sociétés
qui soient spécialisées à qui vous dites
vous prouver votre votre
identité mais qui n'ont pas mais le jour
où vous allez sur telle ou tel site vous
avez ce tiers de confiance et vous ne
déclinez pas une deuxième fois votre
identité donc on peut pas lier votre
identité à la navigation que vous faites
sur Internet c'est important en matière
de droit individuel mais c'est compliqué
mais c'est c'est ces sociétés c'est des
startups qui existent d'ici 2 ou 3 ans
vous allez voir qu'elles vont fleurir
partout et que partout il va y avoir des
sur le contrôle d'âge une solution en
tout cas la solution techniquement elle
existe la question évidemment vous en
avez parlé c'est la question des données
personnelles quel est le danger pour un
utilisateur de Tik Tok aujourd'hui de se
voir capter ces données personnelles
quand vous faites l'application quand
vous inscrivez sur TikTok vous donnez
des permissions les sociétés
spécialisées qui
recense les permissions demandées par
les plateformes sur l'Apple Store ou sur
le Google de Google store
on montrait que Tik Tok demandait en
gros deux fois plus de permission que le
que les autres y compris des permissions
qui ne servent à rien donc quand vous
allez sur Twitter surtout si vous voulez
mettre des vidéos etc Tic-Toc a accès à
votre caméra à votre micro au clavier de
votre ordinateur là où vous tapez les
les mots de passe à la mémoire des
copier-coller la plupart du temps quand
vous passez d'une application à l'autre
vous copiez coller votre mot de passe
des dizaines et des dizaines
d'applications et et par conséquent
je peux même pas vous détailler c'est
une somme
incroyable de de donner je parle même
pas l'adresse IP etc et ça fait partie
des raisons pour lesquelles le
gouvernement a demandé au fonctionnaires
d'État de ne pas télécharger Tik Tok sur
leur téléphone il faut élargir cette
interdiction à d'autres catégories
partir du moment où on pense que les
fonctionnaires d'État posent problème
c'est-à-dire que leur donner pourquoi on
leur demande de fermer les apps parce
qu'il y a des risques d'espionnage sauf
que les données peuvent partir en Chine
et certaines bien entendu partent en
Chine il y a pas que les fonctionnalités
il y a les il y a l'état d'industrie qui
sont sur la liste des industries
stratégiques il est pas il faut le faire
dans ce domaine là puis il y a des tas
de de société qui ont des secrets
industriels comme ça on va pas faciliter
l'espionnage donc oui il faut l'élargir
mais ça pose un problème un autre
problème la Commission européenne qui a
déclenché ça puis ensuite elle a été
suivie par tous les États européens elle
dit il y a
mais on le sait très bien il y a des
risques d'espionnage donc il faut pas
télécharger pour les fonctionnaires de
la Chine mais si il y a ces risques là
ça veut dire que toutes tout le monde
que la Chine a accès aux données de tout
le monde et par conséquent il faut aller
il faut aller plus loin il faut séparer
le lien entre la Chine et Tik Tok c'est
d'ailleurs ce que les Américains
demandent depuis longtemps c'est la
seule solution pour être certain que ces
données ne partent pas vers la Chine
avec comme vous le savez dans toutes les
entreprises et Tik Tok c'est la même
chose que les autres des cellules du
Parti communiste chinois directement et
la loi chinoise qui oblige toute société
à répondre au service de renseignement à
la première demande mais du coup
aujourd'hui Tik Tok c'est un réseau
social ou c'est un réseau contrôlé par
un état par la Chine abus de politique
c'est les deux au départ c'est un réseau
social ça a été créé par des ingénieurs
chinois etc et ça reste un réseau social
un réseau social avec beaucoup de
défauts avec une addictivité
extrême et qui fait qui pose des
problèmes pour le développant des
enfants etc mais c'est en même temps et
la Chine aurait tort de ne pas le faire
de son point de vue c'est en même temps
une sorte de guerre cognitive
aujourd'hui les guerres les compétitions
entre les États sont hybrides les
compétitions entre l'Est et l'Ouest
entre la Chine et la Russie d'un côté et
l'Occident de l'autre sont des guerres
hybrides on le voit tout le temps avec
les élections américaines avec le brexit
et autres et aujourd'hui la Chine a un
instrument dont elle peut se servir pour
n'importe quelle opération d'influence
donc elle peut faire de l'influence
politique et elle fait de l'influence
l'effet à travers tout la Russie agine
elles font aussi bien à travers Facebook
à travers d'autres applications mais sur
Tik Tok c'est encore plus facile puisque
vous avez ce qu'on appelle les pousseurs
vous avez vous n'êtes pas obligé de
faire des fermes à troll avec des
milliers et des milliers de comptes pour
essayer de
d'influencer l'élection américaine par
exemple vous avez ce qu'on appelle les
pousseurs c'est-à-dire que d'un geste du
doigt vous pouvez pousser tel ou tel
site tel ou tel
utilisateur tel ou tel producteur de
vidéo donc c'est encore plus facile dans
votre rapport vous dites il y a des
contenus qui pourraient être biaisés au
profit d'aut
orité des troubles susceptibles
d'affaiblir l'image de la démocratie
est-ce que les autorités chinoises ont
pu alimenter les émeutes de ces derniers
jours en France je ne pense pas je ne
pense pas pour une raison assez assez
simple c'est que ces émeutes ont surpris
tout le monde la veille des émeutes
personne pouvait prévoir qu'il y a eu
qui qu'il y ait ce problème
à Nanterre et la mort de ce jeune homme
et par conséquent c'est pas en 24 heures
que vous montez ce genre de pression que
les réseaux sociaux snapchat Tik Tok
telegram est immédiatement en réagissant
en faisant la cartographie
faciliter ses émeuses c'est une évidence
que ça a été présent que préparé à
l'avance ce serait paranoïaque de le
dire publicité d'autres réseaux sociaux
notamment snapchat est-ce que du coup
vous auriez dû élargir votre commission
d'enquête à d'autres réseaux que TikTok
oui c'est une question qu'on nous pose
la réponse est non d'abord parce que
c'est déjà énorme le travail pour
défricher sur une application comme
celle-là c'est énorme deuxièmement
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a choisi Tik Tok
pour pour un changement d'urgence mais
l'une des raisons c'est que tous les
réseaux sociaux les autres sociaux ils
sont très antérieurs ils existent depuis
une vingtaine d'années et ils ont tous
fait l'objet en France comme ailleurs de
commission d'enquête d'enquête
journalistique etc et Tik Tok ça nous a
d'ailleurs surpris il y a très très peu
de commissions d'enquête sur les
États-Unis une en Australie et puis
c'est tout c'est pour ça que donc il y
avait une nécessité de d'essayer de
décortiquer une une plateforme qui
aujourd'hui n'est pas alors que Facebook
et les autres vous avez eu Snowden vous
avez eu le scandale Cambridge analytique
enfin ça fait des années et des années
qu'on pioche là-dedans Tik Tok voilà
donc on peut pas tout faire à la fois et
deuxièmement il y en a une qui n'était
pas étudiée il était important de de
l'ajouter à la liste de toutes les
plateformes que l'on étudie les réseaux
sociaux qui sont accusés on en a un peu
parlé d'abord participé à l'emballement
des émeutes en France ces derniers jours
Emmanuel Macron a évoqué mardi l'idée de
les couper et puis mercredi finalement
lisez Véran dit qu'il envisageait de
suspendre les fonctionnalités en cas de
nouvelles émeutes le gouvernement recule
un peu là-dessus je pense que le
gouvernement est
embarrassé pour une raison simple c'est
toujours le même problème avec les
réseaux sociaux c'est ce problème de
liberté d'expression
évidemment qu'il y a un problème de
liberté d'expression et par conséquent
quand vous coupez un média etc mais le
problème c'est que les réseaux sociaux
c'est pas des médias comme comme une
télévision par exemple
je vous prends un exemple en 2018 j'ai
demandé
l'interdiction au Sénat à Cédric eau qui
était ministre du numérique je lui ai
demandé l'interdiction de de Spoutnik
qui n'était pas des médias c'était le
KGB enfin le FSB d'aujourd'hui qui
faisait directement et on s'en est
aperçu depuis et on va dire mais
attendez vous on peut pas fermer ça
liberté d'expression etc alors que il y
avait de la propagande russe en chaîne
tout la journée toute la journée tout le
monde le sait aujourd'hui ben je peux
vous dire que le 25 février et le
lendemain on a besoin de l'Ukraine la
Commission européenne tous les pays
européens et les États-Unis ont fermé
RTS Sportic sans s'opposer une seconde
la question parce qu'ils ont découvert
brusquement que c'était pas de la
liberté d'expression mais que c'était de
la propagande d'un État totalitaire
du groupe LR à l'Assemblée il a réagi de
manière un peu ironique à la proposition
Macron couper les réseaux sociaux il dit
couper les réseaux sociaux comme la
Chine c'est ce qu'il a écrit sur Twitter
qu'est-ce que vous dites de ça je
pense que il faut être plus nuancé que
ça et et je vous le dis il y a des
est-ce que quand on a coupé RTS Sputnik
on a fait comme la Chine Corée du Nord
et du et la Russie on a fait ce qui
était une mesure de de sécurité publique
le jour où il sera le jour où on pensera
que le transfert de données sur en Chine
sur Tik Tok et de nature suffisante pour
pour justifier des accusations
d'espionnage par exemple
est-ce que le gouvernement ne je n'en
sais rien je n'en sais rien ce que j'ai
ce qu'on a prouvé dans cette commission
d'enquête c'est que les liens existaient
que les données étaient transférées etc
est-ce qu'elles sont aujourd'hui
utilisées d'une manière agressive d'une
manière de services de renseignement je
moi je ne peux pas aller jusque là je
n'ai pas les moyens d'aller jusque-là je
pense d'ailleurs que les États ont eux
les moyens les services de renseignement
occidentaux ont les moyens le jour où il
sera prouvé si c'est prouvé un jour moi
je dirais
écoutez
j'en sais rien j'en sais rien mais
il faut
comment dire il faut il faut être
pragmatique aujourd'hui Tic-Toc peut
être plus de problèmes à travers une une
un algorithmedictif pour les enfants
pour l'éducation des enfants parce que
c'est c'est un problème majeur c'est les
Chinois parlent de guerre cognitive en
Chine Tik Tok enfin l'équivalent de Tik
Tok et bloqué au bout de 40 minutes
c'est à dire que vous pouvez pas passer
les deux heures que les enfants français
au détriment de leurs études au
détriment de leur sommeil passent sur
des cas en Chine le contenu est beaucoup
plus culturel
par rapport à au contenu un peu
un certain nombre de psychologues qu'on
a interviewé dans le cas de commission
d'enquête par le d'addiction les autres
parlent d'abrutissement
le toute la journée pour regarder des
vidéos de chasse et quand même pas comme
ça que vous allez développer voilà donc
il y a des problèmes posés par toutes
les plateformes il y a des problèmes
spécifiques posés par TikTok et parmi
ces problèmes celui de des liens avec la
Chine et majeur mais celui de la
dictativité d'ailleurs aujourd'hui le
président sont en train de faire la
course à l'échelle avec les trucs pour
faire la même chose qui est vraiment
c'est une dégradation de la qualité de
ces réseaux sociaux qui est déjà pas
terrible pour moi c'est un problème
c'est un problème peut-être que
j'appelle réseau antisociaux
effectivement parce que la haine en
ligne le harcèlement les fake news les
trucages élections ça fait beaucoup
beaucoup de choses il y a un autre
rapport qui a été remis à part le Sénat
c'est le rapport sur le fond Marianne
dérive d'un coup politique manque de
rigueur opacité désinvolture on conduit
au fiasco sont rapporteur Jean-François
ils sont est-ce que le gouvernement peut
mettre la poussière sur le tapis est-ce
que Marlène Schiappa peut encore rester
ministre alors je vais vous faire une
confidence et c'est pas pour mes
défausser mais comme depuis trois
semaines on est en train de terminer la
commission d'enquête on a eu un travail
considérable et je ne franchement je ne
suis pas je me suis pas penché en détail
sur la table
oui la câble la gestion du fond Marianne
oui alors
[Musique]
il parle de négligence dans les et
notamment sur sur du point de vue
judiciaire il parle de négligence comme
on l'a vu comme on l'a vu par exemple
avec Christine Lagarde lors de l'affaire
tapis etc voilà
de la même façon sur le covid
aujourd'hui il y a des commissions il y
a des commissions d'enquêtes il y a des
il y a le cours de justice qui est
saisie etc vous savez le jour où c'est
où les c'est la même chose le jour
des ministres sont toujours censés avoir
la main moi ce que je ce dont je
m'aperçois c'est que sur tous ces sujets
que ce soit sur la faire tapis que ce
soit sur l'affaire de son contaminé à
côté la carrière à Fabius qui en
définitive on s'en aperçu n'avait jamais
été donc vous dites il faut attendre la
fin de l'enquête judiciaire avant de
tirer des conclusions c'est tout le
temps comme ça et
à la fin dans lequel judiciaire la
plupart la plupart du temps j'ai eu un
pas tout le temps mais la plupart du
temps on s'aperçoit que le ballon c'est
dégonflé donc très franchement
aujourd'hui quand vous êtes ministre des
conclusions du rapport du Sénat non le
rapport le chaîna dit nous nous le Sénat
parle de fiasco il parle pas de il parle
pas de de délit il parle pas de crime
etc il parle de fiasco c'est à mon avis
et le mot n'est pas utilisé par hasard
parce que le Sénat aurait pu dire des
montants ou des choses comme ça et pas
il parle de fiasco c'est pas tout à fait
la même chose donc je ce qu'il faut
attendre la fin dans quelle judiciaire
est-ce que parce que ce fond il a été
créé après l'assassinat de Samuel Patier
est-ce que vous avez mesuré le danger
islamiste sur les réseaux sociaux par
exemple les abayas c'est des défis de
Tik Tok bien sûr
bien sûr que sur les réseaux sociaux
mais
ce danger
il est on l'a vu un de multiples
reprises l'élection de Trump est sans
doute dû en partie et en grande partie
aux réseaux sociaux le brexit est une
catastrophe et sans doute dû en grande
partie aux réseaux sociaux et bien
évidemment que les Frères musulmans et
que les islamistes se servent énormément
des réseaux sociaux du TikTok comme les
autres bien entendu mais oui Tik Tok
mais les autres et par conséquent ça
fait partie des plaies des plaies envers
la démocratie c'est c'est Obama qui
disait les réseaux sociaux sont devenus
une des principales menaces contre nos
démocratie et Dieu sait que l'islamisme
est bien entendu une des principales
menaces que démocratie et qu'elle est et
qu'il est très présent sur
réseaux sociaux un dernier mot des
sénatoriales puisque vous êtes président
du groupe vous êtes président du groupe
Les Indépendants ça regroupe des
sénateurs de sensibilité diverses et en
même temps vous êtes membre du bureau
politique d'horizon le parti d'Édouard
Philippe est-ce que vous souhaitez
qu'après les sénatoriales il y ait un
groupe horizon ici au Sénat
nous la plupart des sénateurs qui sont
horizons sont dans ce groupe des
indépendants il côtoie des gens qui sont
très projeux mais qui sont allergiques
ou qui ne veulent pas entrer dans un
parti politique si vous si vous dites on
fait un gros horizon les sénateurs
indépendants ils vont dire mais c'était
pas le c'était pas le but du jeu c'était
pas la règle et par conséquent ils vont
se sentir floués donc moi ma position
qui est d'ailleurs celle d'Edouard
Philippe est très simple c'est que à la
rentrée et j'espère que nous aurons
beaucoup de sénateurs en tout cas plus
de sénateurs à la rentrée nous
continuerons à faire exactement pareil
c'est à dire nous sommes comme le RDSE
comme d'autres dans un groupe qui
accueille à la fois des sénateurs
horizons éventuellement même d'autres
d'autres parties et des sénateurs
indépendants
chez vous parce qu'il y en a qui iront
siégé chez les républicains par exemple
je peux pas je peux pas forcer quicon
mais aujourd'hui si vous regardez tous
les sénateurs horizons à l'exception de
deux l'un qui est hors des pays et
l'autre qui est hallucée sont chez nous
donc pas de raison que ça change mais il
y aura pas de fusion entre le groupe les
indépendants qui contient les sénateurs
horizons et le groupe Renaissance le
groupe RDPI
j'ignore complètement quelles sont la
situation politique
le groupe Renaissance il a été question
à un moment il y a deux ou trois ans de
fusion on a beaucoup parlé ce jeu-là
vous savez le Sénat c'est bon on en
parle beaucoup les gens n'en savent rien
parce que c'est c'est des grenouillages
à l'intérieur du chêne on avait à
l'époque envisagée des rapprochements
soit un intergouv etc avec le RDSE avec
le RDPI ça n'a pas marché je pense
qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde est content
et bien dans son groupe en tout cas ou
des indépendants on est bien et on est
bien toujours un groupe indépendant
comprenait
je pense oui bien sûr merci Claude
malure merci d'avoir été notre invité
merci ce matin on va parler on va
reparler du fond Marianne c'est tout de
suite dans le club des territoires